it's been nearly four months since
hurricane Ian made landfall the category
4 storm touched down on Florida's Coast
in late September leaving a terrible
path of destruction in its wake our Omar
villafranca caught up with some of those
most affected by the storm including
boat owners and the people who serve
them and though on the road to recovery
there's still a lot more work to be done
the boat business at Stacy Stevens
Marina in St James City Florida went
from recreational to recovery after
Hurricane Ian crashed on Shore in late
September it was heartbreaking to see
like 15 years of building up a business
to be wiped out and essentially I'd say
even 24 hours where you know one day it
was good and then the next day it was
completely gone the only charter boat
fishing being done is by cranes fishing
badly damaged boats throwing dreaded out
of the marina these boats that are
behind you are any of them the boats
that would regularly be in your Marina
not one many end up on Stevens Marina
which has now become a boat emergency
room where they're stacked cataloged and
inspected by insurance companies
this new line of work has allowed her to
remain open and keep her employees
working this giant sailboat just lifted
on Shore will be loaded onto a flatbed
where the hull is carefully moved to a
nearby Field in what used to be Steven's
palm tree nursery now turned into a
makeshift boat graveyard There Rose upon
rows of more than 200 vessels and some
mini Yachts await their fate it's still
astounding how many vessels are
completely displaced in the mangroves
just pushed up in places they shouldn't
be on people's yards on people's lifts
that weren't there and as the cleanup
continues in Southwest Florida after the
storm so I think the boat was kind of
coming this way Rob Maine found his
neighbor's 65-foot boat taboo where it
shouldn't be lodged in his backyard
After the Storm ripped it off the dock
yeah it was a complete total shock it
looked bigger than we'd ever thought the
boat looked because now it's halfway on
land and halfway in our backyard and
it'll be there a few more weeks there's
a long waiting list for boat towing
services on Florida's Gulf Coast
Florida's Fish and Wildlife Commission
tasked with clearing these vessels says
there are more than 700 derelict boats
in these Waters but only two-thirds have
been removed
and for taboo's owner Jim Bayer the
price to pull out and fix the damaged
boat is too much I contacted them and
they said to lift that off there with a
huge barge in a crane was going to be
sixteen thousand two hundred dollars
just just to lift out and put it in the
water the insurance company will come
and Tow taboo bone six is Intel Andres
Rosado has spent more than two months
cleaning up Ian's mess see ya thank you
towing damaged boats left on the water
and underwater to land I really hope to
be busy maybe
few more months it's hard to ex say how
how long we're going to be doing this I
hope it's as much time that we have to
clean these whole environments but like
many in this part of Florida Rosado just
wants to get back to when being on the
water wasn't work I do want to be back
towards the normal and that was boaters
going and join restaurants enjoying the
beach enjoying Southwest Florida for CBS
Saturday morning Omar via Franca St
James City Florida
those are the stories like it's the
months later yes and even the years
later for so many places that a lot of
people don't hear about no it's not over
the two weeks after most news crews
leave is right people in the towns like
it's tough to find those good stories
but they're important yeah the cleanup
continues uh Bravo to Omar thanks so
much